foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Phillips Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists we're here with malabama hi
everybody TK Coleman beautiful day it is
oh we got the rest of our team here and
a very special guest she'll be joining
us in a moment coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about avoiding
clutter to create an organized home then
our lightning round segment we've got a
question about home storage a live
stream question and a listener tip for
you you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 390 where we
answer five times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers y'all if you have a question or
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a beautiful voice
recording straight from your phone to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Trinity
I'm Trinity from Eugene Oregon I've
noticed when trying to style my space I
start feeling like I need to acquire
decor and pieces that show that style
but then things start to feel cluttered
is there a way to style my home without
adding more possessions
joining us in the studio today to help
us tackle this question is Kristen
Ziegler from Minima online Kristen is a
professional organizer and she
understands better than anyone the best
way to organize your stuff is to get rid
of most of it Kristen thank you so much
for joining us today happy to be here oh
so let's talk to Trinity specifically
quite often when we get a space what do
we feel compelled to do we feel
compelled to fill it with stuff and
especially stuff that shows my
personality right and now you work with
a lot of clients on their homes and I
know people want to communicate their
personality but one of the worst ways to
do that is by acquiring a bunch of
things how would you talk to Trinity if
she came to you and your business and
said hey I really need help with all of
this clutter that I'm beginning to form
in my life yeah so I feel like authentic
style can't be contrived
so
um I would just focus on identifying the
things that are either useful or
beautiful and I would even go so far as
to say necessary so my um my best
solution is merge Form and Function even
the necessary things are a chance for
you to show your I would say preferences
and priorities is a better word than
style because I think that um that gets
at the authenticity of who you are as a
person which can't be contrived versus
style to me is more of a surface level
thing yeah so when I think about my home
or I think about someone else's home
quite often it tells me about who they
are if there's a bunch of excess and
what I often tell people is when in
doubt subtract yes it's not about adding
more because like oh you know it feels a
little bit like me but it's a little bit
chaotic maybe if I add just a little bit
more a little here a little there and
before you know it you have all of this
excess yeah there isn't a whole lot of
function there's a lot of form yeah and
it just starts getting in the way yeah
so I feel like
um
organization without minimizing is like
form without function and I I've been
reading this book called subtract by
lady klotz have you heard of it yes yeah
I figured
um and I think there's such a missed
opportunity through subtraction in
between problem solving I think
instinctually like biologically we go to
adding even I like we just moved in
September and I even catch myself doing
it that space feels off I need to add a
picture I need to add a vase I need to
add a thing and every single time this
requires the approach of subtraction
requires a lot more time in patience but
I always tell my clients there's no rush
it took me seven years to get our last
house exactly how I wanted it and that's
and then I moved
time for a new project that's another
conversation so let me ask you with
respect to someone like like Trinity if
he does feel like oh this space feels a
little empty now obviously Trinity you
are complete even in an empty room
absolutely but if you walk into a room
and you're like oh there's something off
about this it does feel empty yeah what
kind of questions do you ask uh so my
architect brain wants to say like how
can you possibly rearrange or reimagine
the things that are already in the space
usually I'll go big when something feels
off in a space like completely change it
up and play and really let go of my
attachments to the way it is and usually
the end result that feels balanced is
really similar to where I started but
there's a few subtle tweaks that I
discovered which I couldn't have if I
hadn't let go let let go and explore it
a little bit more yeah I don't know how
interior designers like plan the whole
Space out and then do I feel like
there's so much magic in the in the
doing like the design build approach I
love your observation that authentic
style can't be contrived and I was going
to ask you well can you say more about
that and then you followed it up with
saying focus more on what you prefer
yeah rather than on what seems stylish
and it sounds like you're saying hey
what feels good what functions well
rather than what you think is going to
look cool to someone else because you
can't control it you can't control that
yeah not at all yeah it's really nice
I'm I am not an interior designer but
like I'm thinking about how I would
approach the situation I mean obviously
Trinity likes some stuff you know it's
some decorations um you can't have all
the decorations as Trinity pointed out
because then you feel overwhelmed would
it be a good approach like I don't know
maybe set a boundary of like uh a couple
things and like see how those two things
look in that room or even like maybe
start with nothing just start with like
a wall can you do an accent wall like
paint it or wallpaper it or something I
don't know I'm just trying to think of
what they did back in the 90s when I
worked for my dad my dad's painting and
wallpaper business yeah it seems like
you could add some things more
intentionally rather than trying to put
all the things in there and yeah and I
think that goes back to the process of
simplifying is identifying the things
that really spark a feeling for you or
add value to your life and working with
those things
um but yeah I always like to bring
plants into a space like natural
elements yeah
um I think you can have too many plants
though but it yeah yeah definitely what
I've noticed with the spaces your own
space tends to be more minimal than
maybe a lot of the people you work with
then all of the people I work with yeah
and it could be that they don't have an
aspiration necessarily to get down to
the more Stark level right um and that's
okay I mean uh later in this episode in
fact uh Trinity I'd love to send you if
you're not a patreon supporter every
week on Fridays we do a minimalist home
tour and this week we are actually going
to do we're gonna take a look at my
living space and it's really Stark it's
even more Stark than yours but I don't
prescribe that to anyone and what I love
about what you do is you're not
prescribing that either this is what's
ideal for me and it is one recipe it's a
template.com which you can add you can
subtract and uh when you work with
people you don't say well you need to
get down to this particular level
absolutely not so my company's name
Minima is actually a calculus term I'm a
huge math nerd and but I also love Arts
that's why I studied architecture but
Minima is the lowest value on a function
curve and so I always say I want to help
our clients get to their Minima and
that's different for everyone I'm all
the way down I feel like you know and
you're all the way like at the bottom of
the curve but not everybody wants to be
there and I feel like even if I can
impart a little bit of minimalist wisdom
I've done my job I'm not going to say
well you have failed and I fire you as a
client because you kept too much stuff I
mean that that's not helpful so yeah
yeah well you know it reminds me of
those articles about CEOs who read one
book A Week the lesson to be taken from
that isn't to stress yourself out about
reading as much as the CEOs but like hey
maybe I could read more yeah I'm
inspired by this I want to you know take
a little bit from that and see how it
can improve my life so one question for
you so let's say with Trinity's
situation maybe she has a chair or a
picture some cherished piece of
furniture that really worked for the old
place she gets into the new place and
what if it just doesn't fit with the
style of what she wants to do does she
has to have to get rid of it or what do
you do
um I would give it some time but I
personally I am very adaptive to the
space that I live in I think a lot of
people have this idea about forcing uh
their needs or their you know specific
Vision onto a space I think the best
um result is when we look at our space
and think about a harmonious
relationship like oh this space has
these beautiful windows I don't want to
block it crowded out with a bunch of
clutter just kind of leaning in asking
the space What It Wants to be
um does this space uh serve your purpose
with that chair in it or not
um that's only something that she can
figure out
it's interesting like I don't really
crave to put anything on the walls or
and my wife is the same exact way but
it's funny like we'll get these things
in our lives like uh her dad is an
artist and he gave us like a couple of
nice paintings of Montana
um Josh gave us an awesome picture of me
and Mariah from 10 years ago we're so
old dude anyway
um it was a beautiful picture
beautifully framed
um I had a friend who I did that sent me
a painting but like I get these things
and I'm like oh wow like I'm compelled
to put this on the wall and find a spot
for it so then I kind of make it work
with the room we have a lot of plants in
there yeah um but yeah I wish I had that
that vision of what I wanted to do with
my space it's more like kind of people
will offer me something and I'm like oh
yeah I could totally see that like going
up on the wall that's beautiful or no
thanks um thanks for the offer though
yeah and so when someone like Ryan comes
to you Chris and they're like I just
don't have the vision for this I know I
really appreciate what you how you've
curated your space and well I may not be
that strict with my own space I'm not
able to curate my own Vision how I even
want this place to look I've got certain
things things that I like things that
I've owned for a while and some things
may work in the space some some things
not what's your process of sort of going
through the home yeah
um so
so like
Jen
you know it's something you can always
do from the outset it requires a little
bit of Discovery and play and and you
know maybe putting that picture that was
gifted up on the wall and then deciding
that doesn't feel right and what feels
right to you might not feel right to
someone else but it only really matters
if it feels right to you I think just
experimenting and playing and not being
afraid to put holes in the wall it's
just paint yeah
um yeah and just
just doing it yeah yeah I think the
experimentation piece is really
important here because as soon as you
set it it's not set forever it's not
there Nothing in life is right right and
so you got to us uh you you got to a end
point with your space where you felt
like it you had perfected it where it
was done your space was done and then
you decide well it's time to move and
the things that worked in that previous
space unless your new space looks nearly
identical nothing like it yeah and so
they may not work yeah and so being
willing to let go of those things we
hold on to from the past and they may
have a sort of sentimental resonance
with us and so we hold on to them even
though they don't work anymore they've
ceased to add value in fact quite often
what happens when we hold on and it's
getting in the way it actually drains
the value from our life yeah yeah
absolutely so
um I also yeah I think it's really
important to be able to let go of things
during a move or as your life changes
um sometimes a fresh set of eyes too can
kind of come in if you're not sure you
could ask for feedback take it or leave
it you know it's your space
um I also look for pieces uh that are
flexible so I invested in this hay sofa
that I love and I was really hoping it
was going to fit into the new house and
the good news is that it did but I was
ready to sell it if it didn't but it's
modular so I could take a piece out of
the middle and it could get smaller if
it needed to so things that are flexible
that are not so specific to a space
especially if it's more of an investment
yeah they're good things to look for
yeah I always call Josh I'll just send
him a picture be like hey does this look
all right there's my outfit or like
something I'm hanging on the wall or
yeah like can we do this for minimal
home tour is this a good picture
uh next week by the way I've seen some
beautiful pictures of your previous home
I'd love to feature that uh for our
patrons as well so every week we do this
this weekly minimalist home tour our
patrons will send in things in fact last
week we had the most beautiful kitchen
I've ever seen was it I think it was in
Estonia it's pretty gorgeous it was
amazing but the art was the view from
the kitchen I mean it was like as soon
as you saw out the window and uh for
someone like Ryan who doesn't want to
put a bunch of things on the wall or
someone like me or my wife Bex we don't
put anything on the walls generally and
and I I think that's that allows us to
keep it simple because we feel compelled
to constantly as soon as you have a
blank wall I should fill this with
something but then when I see a space
like your space there's plenty of blank
walls and it doesn't look empty it looks
calm it looks peaceful it looks stunning
thank you and when I see someone's home
with a whole bunch of things on the wall
it can be intentional it can be well
curated but more off than not it's just
like hey I need to throw something up
here yeah and then it just becomes
clutter it's not intentional
um so I feel like so I identify as very
visually sensitive I'm sure some some of
y'all here do as well yeah we heard of
highly sensitive yeah my wife's a highly
sensitive person so is my daughter so am
I yeah
um and it manifests itself largely in
the visual sense so I have an uncle who
I wrote about in your class actually
okay who's a total maximalist and I can
appreciate his space because that's what
works for him that's the amount of
things that feel right for his
sensitivity but for me I couldn't live
that way because it would stress me out
but that's literally just how I'm like
my physio physiology
yeah I think about my mom she was a
maximalist but she had a great style
yeah uh I think people like Axel vavort
who's a great interior designer and but
he's a he really appreciates objects
more than I do there's a lot of form
there and it may not have a particular
function but they have an aesthetic
value and a beauty to him that it's
really hard to pull off if you're just
willy-nilly grabbing random some objects
yeah you could tell he's not doing it
there's something intentional behind it
my mom did the same thing she had a lot
of stuff but it was intentional and I
applaud that if you're being intentional
with very few things or you're being
intentional with a lot of things it's
not going to stress you out because you
are constantly questioning the objects
in your home yeah and I think it's
actually more of a challenge to create
Beauty with less but I love the
challenge
um I think it's easier to make a space
Feel Complete by adding but I thrive
from from asking myself how few things
can I have because for me it's less to
maintain it's less money to spend less
decisions decision fatigue is real
that's part of minimalism for me
um yeah so I think that you know again
going back to the beginning of our
conversation our home is a manifestation
of our inner world and it can be
beautifully curated in a maximalist way
or minimalist way or somewhere in
between but yeah for me I've learned
that um the maximalist would stress me
out you often tell me yeah you often
help people unpack their homes as well I
assume that's during a move yep where
someone's moving and it's like I don't
even know what to do with all this stuff
yeah now when you're unpacking do you
quite often get rid of most of the
things that are being unpacked I don't
know about most I think the percentage
probably varies client to client but
it's such a great opportunity you have
to touch the thing anyway like let's
decide if it's gonna go in your cabinet
or closet or out the door with us yes so
yeah and it's not about you getting rid
of their stuff it's about them making
that decision yeah and maybe you can ask
the questions that facilitate that's
just it yeah the letting go so so much
of our work is just asking the right
questions we can't tell someone what's
right or wrong for them we can just find
the right questions to ask do you have
some of your favorite questions you see
come up again and again with clients oh
yeah so
um
I have a whole list and a blog post
um I think
do you love this thing are you keeping
it because you should keep it do you
have another thing that could serve the
same purpose
um yeah like with it depends on the
category too like with clothing does it
fit do you love it does it suit your
current lifestyle or is it part of like
some past corporate career that you're
not in anymore
um yeah just also like asking the space
what does it want to be and respecting
the boundaries of that space like okay
we've minimized based on these factors
but it doesn't fit so we need to do
another pass so that you can live
comfortably here yeah I love that
because yeah everyone has different
preferences in fact some people because
of the Paradox of choice they want a
list of all the things they should have
yeah and asking those questions it's
you're really helping that person
discover their own preferences yeah
absolutely it's such a huge Discovery
process I have a client who started
working with us to declutter her home
and
um she did that and then a couple she's
become a good friend and a couple years
later she called me up and she's like um
our work together has finally inspired
me to get my finances in order because I
had that Clarity and then a couple years
later she said I'm finally getting my
health in order and I've I've created a
capsule wardrobe because everything's in
flux so I need it to be really simple
and I was like that's amazing just the
way that it has a ripple effect and yeah
that's cool that willingness to let go
when repeated it becomes habitual not
that you should make it a habit but if
you let go you let go you keep asking
those questions I remember when I first
started letting go I asked the same
question over and over with every object
until it became a feeling not just an
intellectual exercise exactly and that
question was does this thing add value
to my life and I asked that does this
thing add value to my life does this
thing add and the more I ask it I could
just start to look at an object and know
like no yeah that's access yeah same
Trinity thank you so much for your
question Ryan
what's up what time is it you know what
time it is it's time for the lightning
round where we answer your questions
from Tick Tock yes indeed you can follow
the minimalist on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalists
now during the lightning round we each
have 60 seconds to answer your question
with a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like we have a
question right now from Michael there
are so many container options plastic
totes canvas containers bankers boxes
and so on when keeping things organized
how do you decide on the best container
for the job Kristen I'm going to set you
up here give me 60 seconds Professor
Sean and I'll set you up for this
lightning round you don't have to be
super pithy but just something within 60
seconds here for Michael
Michael the best way to organize your
stuff
to get rid of most of it you got a lot
of things in your home in your basement
in your garage
in your attic in your kitchen in your
cabinets in your closets in Your
Entertainment console
you've got a lot of stuff
instead of simply trying to organize it
with more plastic totes more canvas
containers more bankers boxes and
printer paper boxes
consider getting rid
of most of it
and then when you finally reach that end
point
what do you have
you have a few things the might might
require a plastic tote or might require
some sort of canvas box to put it in but
you're going to need far fewer things to
organize if you have far fewer things to
organize
all right so to play off of that
um
go for it
to follow up from that I would say when
you have done that you get to spend a
little bit more time thinking about what
containers are going to work best for
you and what I would suggest is thinking
about how is this solution going to
still serve me and my space five or ten
years from now
so I look for things when I need a
container that are modular and versatile
and interchangeable so my personal
favorite is from Muji which is a
Japanese brand and I have the same
containers in the kitchen in the home
office closet in the linen closet and as
our needs inevitably change we can take
a container from one space and swap it
out in another and we don't have to keep
buying and things don't fall apart and
become disorganized again what I love
about that is it's really simple and the
containers you're using they're not
going to be super bright colors not
there's anything wrong with that but
having this Baseline for organization so
that you're not constantly having to
update yeah five ten years from now
these will still likely work for me and
if they don't work then of course you
can let the containers go as well yeah
let's get 60 seconds on the clock for
Ryan Nicodemus let's do it
TK no one wins with storage bins
let me let me expound a little bit when
it comes to storage bins if a
professional organizer shows up the very
first day with storage bins what is that
going to do for that for that client
it's going to give them permission to
hold on to more right away they're like
oh there's some more stuff to hold on to
so no one wins with storage bins also
means no one really wants to have
storage bins who is like oh I'm so glad
I bought these storage bins they look so
awesome we can get them to look as
pretty as possible and there are some
really well designed ones out there but
no one feels good about the storage bins
that they own that's so spot on because
here's the thing you would rather a
hundred percent of the time not need the
storage bins and you're right if you
need the thing that's in the storage
bins you would prefer for just
materialized when you needed it and then
you didn't have to put it away or store
it but it is true sometimes we have to
store some things but if you show up
first with a pile of storage bins you're
going to store way too many things
ladies and gentlemen TK Coleman with 60
seconds on the clock
hahaha the best option is the one that
sets you free what's the definition of
having options it means there are more
possibilities on the table than what you
are capable of taking advantage of so
how do you downsize that sense of
overwhelm that comes from having so many
opportunities before you you simply
choose Freedom it's like I tell my
students when they say hey TK what's the
best book to buy the one you'll actually
read if you buy the books that you think
will make you look smart they won't do
you any good if they remain on the Shelf
in the same way if you exercise the
options that make you look good it's not
going to do anything for you if those
options aren't actually used and if they
aren't leveraged in order to make you
free oh spot on man because what's going
to happen is I can go to Walmart or The
Container Store or wherever
and we just had a whole conversation on
the private podcast about storage bins
and and excess stuff going in these bins
I'm giving myself not just permission to
hide the excess I have now but to
accumulate even more excess because at
least it's well organized excess but
well organized access is still excessive
we're gonna check in with the patreon
live stream in a moment in Alabama but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists well it's a
brand new month this episode comes out
on the first of the month and guess what
that means it's a new opportunity to
play the 30-day minimalism game a lot of
people feel overwhelmed they don't know
where to start when they start to let go
they look around their home and they say
I've got 300 000 items in here
I'm just gonna throw my hands up I don't
know what to do well if you're anything
like me decluttering is kind of boring I
I don't like decluttering but it's
essential for many of us to get the
access out of the way so we found a way
to make it a bit more fun with some
friendly competition
and the way the 30-day minimalism game
works you can find all the details that
the minimalists.com game it's completely
free to play we don't want anything from
you for that you can download our free
minimalism game calendar there as well
but you partner up with a friend a
family member A co-worker at the
beginning of the month and you said the
first day of the month we're just gonna
get rid of one item
starts off really easy anyone can pick
just one item you can pick Ryan usually
just picks one paper clip
secondary months two paper clips and by
the end of the month I've gotten rid of
almost 500 paper clips
the sad part is on the 31st of each
month he goes buys more paper clips
hey about the game is you get the the
rules whoever goes the longest
throughout the month wins so first day
of the month you I'm gonna get rid of
this shirt second day of the month I'm
gonna get rid of this pair of pants and
wait actually let me get a pair of these
shoes I think that counts as two things
one shoe two shoe okay great however you
want to count it go for it it starts to
get Difficult by the middle of the month
because day 13 you're like I have to get
rid of 13 things a day and 14 things
tomorrow what am I going to get rid of
whoever goes the longest wins so you bet
whatever you wanted the beginning of the
month and if you both make it to the end
of the month then you've both won
because as Ryan just said you've gotten
rid of about 500 items and that's a
really great place to get started if you
want to download the free minimalism
game calendar it's over at the
minimalists.com game we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well Alabama
let's check in with the patreon live
stream any comments for us we have a
comment here from Crystal she says the
Richmond Meetup Group sends our love to
KZ
so back in uh 2014 we went to a hundred
different cities left behind a hundred
free local meetup groups over at
minimalist.org and that's what she's
referencing there so if you want to find
open-minded people who are also
decluttering their lives in different
ways whether it's decluttering their
home decluttering their finances
decluttering their relationships
minimalist.org is a great place to find
and connect with people locally
we'll check back in with the live stream
here in a bit from Alabama first what
else you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
my name is Chris Urban and I'm a
computer tech calling
just great for some I personally dislike
cloud storage because I never want to
risk my personal privacy if there was a
security issue with the cloud service
I'll be facing sorting my own digital
files this month and we'll be doing it
with two hard drives which will be the
same model of ties and will be in raid
one without going into too much detail
raid one is a way to set up hard drives
to be mere images of each other every
time a file is added to one it goes to
the other also it appears as a one drive
in the operating system
if one drug fails the other will still
have the data it's a great way to back
up important data and avoid the cloud
I realize this sounds very complicated
but it really isn't search online for
how to set up raid 1 and I am sure
you'll find plenty of guides
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 390 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions like
how would you recommend storing small
kitchen gadgets and appliances how can I
organize my home workspace when I have
to share the room with the rest of my
family I heard you guys discuss
contaminants in your tap water how do
you filter your water plus a million
more questions for Kristen and the
minimalists also this week a private
tour of my Stark but peaceful 250 square
foot living space and much much more of
less and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
at patreon.com the minimalist or click
the link in the description to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to all of our podcast
archives all the way back to episode
zero zero one and if you're still on the
fence here's a testimonial from one of
our lovely patreon supporters Jessica
says hey I've been following you guys
for a while I knew someone was following
us Ryan
I thought you're just being paranoid
she says I've been following you guys
for a while but I am a new patreon
subscriber your private podcast is as
refreshing as a cold drink in the heat
thank you for bringing meaning into my
life not just through your minimalist
lifestyle but through your wisdom and
thought-provoking private conversations
wow Jessica big thanks to you also big
thanks to Kristen Ziegler from
minimaonline.com ladies and gentlemen
Kristen Ziegler yeah
I shot
just one message please let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it